These are the 14 strongest characters in One
Piece whose true powers are still unexplained.
Starting with Monkey D. Dragon.
This mysterious man is the absent father of
Luffy and the leader of the Revolutionary
Army.
His stated goal is to take down the corrupt
nobles who rule the World Government.
And while we’ve never seen him fight, whenever
he shows up strange things always happen.
For instance, when he appeared in Logue Town
in chapter 100 Luffy was saved by a freak
lightning storm that arrived out of nowhere.
Or in the Goa kingdom, strong winds saved
citizens from a raging fire when Dragon arrived
at the island.
And these examples have led many to speculate
that Dragon has a devil fruit or an ancient
weapon that can control the weather.
What a power to have in this world covered
with water.
We also know that Luffy likely gets his unbreakable
will and haki from Dragon.
And on top of that, he is also the most wanted
man in the world, and judging by the rest
of his family, Dragon should be one of the
most powerful characters in the story.
However, there is also some evidence that
Dragon may not be as strong as many people
think he is.
For example, Blackbeard was able to destroy
the Revolutionary army’s base.
And while Dragon and the revolutionaries easily
survived, it makes me wonder how strong Dragon
actually is.
But while we can possibly question Dragon’s
strength, one undeniable powerhouse in Luffy’s
family is his grandpa Monkey D. Garp.
The Hero of the Marines, Garp is a famous
retired Vice-admiral who was the rival and
friend of former pirate king Gol D. Roger.
He is respected by LITERALLY every single
marine and was even offered the position of
admiral many times, though he always turned
it down.
He is even capable of defeating Yonko level
characters, like we see in the special chapter
Strong World.
In this chapter, he and former fleet admiral
Sengoku take down Shiki, who was Roger’s
main pirate rival.
But what have we actually seen from Garp?
While we’ve never really seen him fight,
we do know he has ridiculous physical strength.
He throws cannonballs like bullets, brawls
with his fists, and has top-tier haki.
And while he did not participate during the
war at marineford, Garp certainly felt capable
of killing Akainu after the blood thirsty
admiral punched a hole through Ace.
But is he one of the strongest characters
alive?
In the past, we know he rivaled Whitebeard
and even teamed up with Roger to take down
Rocks D. Xebec, probably the most powerful
pirate in history.
But if he is on their level, do we really
believe he is just throwing fists with all
these top tier fighters.
I mean every other elite fighter in the series
uses some kind of weapon or ability.
A sword.
A gun.
A devil fruit.
But we haven’t seen Garp use any of these.
Surely he won’t just chuck cannonballs when
he tries to rescue Koby from Blackbeard.
So is he actually hiding a secret ability
or is he just the greatest Haki master in
all of One Piece?
And what if I told you that Garp was probably
not even the strongest marine?
One character whose powers are a complete
mystery is the World Government Commander
in Chief, Kong.
But just look at this absolute chad of a man.
Who would want to step up to this dude in
a fight?
Even though we don’t know his individual
fighting strength, we know that he controls
the marines and Cipher Pol.
And since marines are usually promoted based
on fighting ability, Kong must have incredible
powers since he was the fleet admiral before
Sengoku and Akainu.
And there is a likely explanation for why
Oda is keeping his abilities a mystery.
You see, he could very easily be one of the
final opponents the straw hats face on their
journey, and we will learn more about his
powers in the final battles ahead.
And speaking of straw hats, there have always
been many questions about Zoro and Sanji’s
true abilities.
Like, does Zoro’s unrelenting drive to be
the strongest swordsman in the world mean
he will unlock conqueror’s Haki?
And how exactly can Sanji light his legs on
fire?
Well during the Wano arc, we finally got these
answers.
After Zoro cuts Kaido deep enough to leave
a scar, the Yonko himself tells us that Zoro
just attacked using Conqueror’s haki.
No other confirmation needed.
And as for Sanji, it turns out that he has
genetically modified genes.
These genes are from an almost extinct race
of sky people that have the ability to create
fire at will.
Now that we finally know how these unique
abilities work, it hopefully won’t be long
until Zoro and Sanji reach the level of the
rest of the characters on this list.
Another character we just learned a whole
lot more about is Shanks.
What we’ve long know is that as a child,
Shanks was a cabin boy on Roger’s crew.
And before losing his arm, he could duel evenly
with the strongest swordsman in the world.
He even stopped the war at Marineford without
even fighting.
And in the most insane conqueror’s haki
flex in the story, he made an admiral run
away crying from miles away.
But it gets even more insane thanks to the
information in the booklet released with Film
Red.
In it we learn that Shanks can coat his sword
in a fiery aura similar to Luffy’s Red Hawk
attack.
Also, Shanks’ nickname in battle is “*the
killer of Observation Haki”* meaning that
he can even stop other strong characters like
Luffy from using their future sight ability.
Mind-blowing.
Truly, Shanks is the definition of a badass
character.
And he is going to show Luffy that there is
still much to learn about haki.
But despite all this new information, there
is still so much about his powers and goals.
Certainly he didn’t have a devil fruit at
the start of the series, but it is possible
he ate one between chapter 1 and becoming
a Yonko.
Besides his fighting skill, he has the clout
to drink booze with Whitebeard, the influence
to stop Kaido from coming to Marineford, and
the swagger to walk into Mary Geoise to chat
with the Gorosei.
Also, it is possible that he could be a world
noble or even something more crazy like Rocks
D. Xebex’s son.
Whatever the truth is, we should find out
soon as he is finally going to take an active
role in the search for the One Piece.
And similar to Shanks, another pirate searching
for that legendary treasure is Blackbeard.
This man is also a Yonko, one of the most
dangerous pirates in the seas, and is Luffy’s
main rival to become pirate king.
The most mysterious thing about him are his
devil fruit powers.
That’s right, I said POWERS.
By some unexplained process, Blackbeard can
use both the Darkness fruit, a power that
is a whole mystery by itself, and the Tremor
fruit, which is said to have the ability to
destroy the entire world.
So what DO WE KNOW about this hidden ability
that allows Blackbeard to have multiple devil
fruits?
Some theories I’ve covered in other videos
range from his original devil fruit being
the three headed dog Cerberus or a mythical
Octopus, him having a god-like fruit just
like Luffy, or even Blackbeard being triplets
that are stuck in one body.
Each of these theories could explain how he
was able to eat a second devil fruit, and
many wonder if he will eat a third one before
his final fight with Luffy.
Plus, we still don’t know if Blackbeard
has conqueror’s haki.
Though one thing we do know is that he has
horrible taste in pies and drinks, at least
according to Luffy
But perhaps Blackbeard’s most important
secret is his connections to the legendary
pirate Rocks D. Xebec.
Blackbeard could be Rocks’ son, his clone,
or even somehow have Rocks living inside of
him.
Hold on, what?
One of the strongest pirates ever… living
inside of another pirate.
That’s right.
In One Piece, anything is possible.
Rocks D. Xebec is surrounded with so much
mystery that we are dying to find out what
happened to him and more importantly, how
he was so powerful.
What we DO know is that Rocks was an infamous
pirate 40 years ago and that his goal was
to become King of the World.
To do that, he ruled over the most insane
pirate crew ever and was only stopped when
Garp and Roger teamed up during the incident
on God Valley.
However, the island where this famous battle
occurred was erased from history and we’ve
never had confirmation of Rocks’ death or
his powers.
But if it took the marines, Garp, and Roger
to defeat Rocks, then he must have been a
monstrous fighter.
Many theories point to him being the former
user of Blackbeard’s Darkness fruit or another
overpowered devil fruit such as the lightning
fruit.
Whatever it was, if his goal was to conquer
the world, then he surely would have possessed
one of the strongest fruits in the story and
incredibly strong will and haki.
Another participant in the famous God Valley
battle was the Dark King Rayleigh.
Rayleigh was Roger’s former Vice-Captain,
and is said to be nearly as strong as the
former pirate king himself.
He is one of the most powerful swordsmen in
the series.
He can easily go head to head with a marine
admiral and he is a master of all forms of
haki.
We also know Rayleigh doesn’t have a devil
fruit as he has been shown swimming multiple
times, which makes his powers even more impressive.
So you might be wondering why he is in this
video.
Well, he is one of the few living people who
have been to Laugh Tale, and it makes me wonder
if he is hiding some unknown power that we
have yet to see in the series.
And you can’t talk about Rayleigh without
discussing Roger.
The former pirate king and the man who kicked
off the great pirate age.
Roger is undoubtedly one of the strongest
One Piece characters ever.
We do know that was a master swordsman, who
wielded one of only twelve existing Supreme
Grade Blades.
He was not a devil fruit user, but there have
been many strange occurrences when we see
him in battle.
For example, in this battle against Shiki,
a sudden storm saves the Roger pirates from
certain death.
Sound familiar?
[show luffy logue town storm] And just like
Luffy, Roger is one of the very few characters
to have the Voice of All Things.
Roger could also have haki abilities a level
above anything we have seen in the story,
similar to Shanks.
Also, there’s this giant egg on Roger’s
ship that has never been explained so far
in the story.
Seriously, what is this thing?
An ancient weapon?
A mythical creature?
We don’t know, but whatever it is, it is
just one more mystery surrounding the full
powers of the former pirate king and what
exactly he found so funny at Laugh Tale.
And while we don’t know what Roger found
there, we can guess that it was something
Imu wants erased from history.
This secret ruler of the world has appeared
in just 18 panels IN THE ENTIRE STORY and
has never said a word!
We don’t even know if they are a man or
a woman.
But everytime they do appear we get world
changing events.
We know that the Gorosei take orders from
Imu.
They sit on the Empty Throne, which we were
told NO ONE is allowed to do.
And we are led to believe that they can order
the destruction of entire islands [show destruction
of Lulusia].
But despite Imu’s limited panels, they are
clearly set up as one of the main antagonists
the straw hats will face before the end of
the story.
And so we have to ask what their powers may
be?
Do they control an ancient weapon?
Do they have a super powered devil fruit?
Can their observation haki span the entire
world?
What is the deal with this giant straw hat?
And most importantly, just how long has Imu
been alive?
It is very possible that Imu has lived since
the Void Century, secretly pulling the strings
of the world to keep themselves alive and
in power.
I know I can’t wait to find out the answers
to all of Imu’s mysteries.
And while Imu is likely one of the final villains,
the Gorosei seem to be the next World Government
opponents the straw hats will face.
These Five Elder Stars rule the world government
for Imu.
They have complete control over the marines,
Cipher Pol, and technology developed by the
genius scientist, Dr. Vegapunk.
And they are willing to have entire islands
destroyed to protect their deepest secrets,
though at least some of them show remorse
over doing so.
While we don’t know if they have been alive
for as long as Imu, they are certainly not
your average world noble.
Despite never seeing them fight, it is likely
that each of these men are unafraid of battle.
Many show scars and one carries what is likely
a cursed sword.
As a group they were not concerned about being
in the presence of Shanks without any guards
to protect them.
Plus they felt perfectly safe bossing around
Akainu.
*blows air* No one in their right mind does
that if they can’t defend themselves.
In fact, Saint Saturn here is heading into
a battle ground on Egghead Island.
And Kizaru shows him an uncommon amount of
respect.
Truly we don’t know what the Gorosei are
capable of, but get ready because those answers
are likely coming soon.
Now, one character that the Gorosei definitely
want eliminated is the smartest man in the
world, Dr. Vegapunk.
In the current arc, we learn that Vegapunk
has studied the Void Century.
This is a blank 100 year gap in history from
800 years ago, and since Vegapunk has studied
it, that means he likely knows information
about the ancient kingdom and its incredible
technology.
But it also means the government is trying
to kill him.
And while his Brain fruit powers don’t have
much use in battle, Vegapunk’s inventions
certainly make him one of the most dangerous
character’s in the world.
For example, just two of these Seraphim he
created are capable of making even a Yonko
hesitate.
And Vegapunk has even successfully recreated
actual devil fruits.
Such an insane ability.
Imagine more lightning users, more dragons,
or even more Caribou’s… wait no.
Please no more Caribou’s.
Plus, it’s likely we haven’t seen everything
Vegapunk is capable of.
If he really was close to uncovering the secrets
of the Ancient Kingdom’s technology, then
the world is definitely about to change.
And one character that Vegapunk likely learned
a lot about is the mysterious Joy Boy.
In chapter 628, we learn that Joy Boy was
a person from the void century who was part
of the legendary ancient kingdom.
While it is likely that Joy Boy was once an
actual person, it seems the phrase has become
more of a title.
We know this because when Luff y awakened
the Sun God Nika fruit, Zunesha, this giant
walking elephant with an island on their back,
announced that Joy Boy had returned.
And while Luffy was bouncing around with his
insane new powers, we don’t know exactly
how this made him Joy Boy or how he connects
to the person from the Void Century.
Not much is known about the actual powers
of the past Joy Boy, but we can assume that
this person also possessed the Nika fruit,
and it was their role to bring freedom and
joy to the world.
The Joy Boy from the past probably also had
access to incredible technology.
In recent chapters, we learn that the Void
Century was a time of great technological
advancements and that the world today is still
trying to relearn all the secrets that were
lost.
Also, Joy Boy could likely use the Ancient
Weapons.
One of them could have been used to command
Zunesha and if he really had this power, then
we have to wonder how he and the ancient kingdom
ever lost to the world government 800 years
ago.
But Eiichiro Oda, the author of one piece,
has left us clues that we can use to learn
more about this mysterious figure, the battle
during the void century, and how the knowledge
Joy Boy left behind will change the one piece
world forever.
Everything that we know I explain in this
video right here [Everything we know about
Joy Boy video].
Shanks for watching.